one time I like gave offerings to the
monks I was in uh yes yes I did there
was a opportunity like in the city that
I was in every morning at like 4 30 a.m
or something like that the monks like
walked through the city and so you can
go and like give them offerings please
don't tell me you did like some drunk
guy thing you walked out through the
[__] 40 I'm like
you need to take a load off man
guys I've been thinking a lot clink 30
rack yeah yeah sorry it's kind of heavy
I know you're you got a long walk ahead
of you I don't know y'all work out
though yeah new condition for this [__]
yeah all right you're going up that
mountain where you're gonna need this I
brought you guys half a hot dog
I got last night I ate half before I
went to bed and I wrapped it up in
tinfoil so you can have this they don't
have a fridge in the hostel so I
apologize it's just a little weird but